what's up fool podcast was so full
podcast coming to you right now
everywhere on a Friday morning Friday
afternoon or some of you guys are way
into Monday we got Rodrigo Torrance
right here
co-host of the year and also the host of
the yeah my podcast half hour and not
anymore man I got a lady all right P
jerk-off hours we got at least all right
here man the wheel the steel that and I
just I'm trying to save it all for her
how thoughtful it's a wasted like I mean
how thoughtful I don't know a laughing I
consider but you say that load and
watching our guest party with a grenade
and if I had a grenade tattoo Bravo drop
below zero I'll be boy hold on [ __ ] hey
but you know what TV kill me right here
oh yeah wow the giver this our guest has
a young man tattoo we're gonna get back
to here right now
whoever this flyer here the next 40
minutes even it's a bus driver for the
Simpsons people I'm gonna I don't met
him personally by the way was so yeah
but the first time I heard of him was
when I was in Las Vegas doing the show
we were doing a triple B and Birdman
from San Jose Hannah a show and after
boom you doing over there - oval stone -
Rob right and I think the chill got
canceled or they thought it busted a
bunch of fools with marijuana was lock
him in yeah you were doing a wee short
yeah that's the first time I heard your
name beretti's oh really
I heard about him through a zone and I
seen you in a couple fires well that's
amazing yeah in the last probably five
years right do your thing right yeah
there I've been trying to take off my
clothes push a post um what's the name
out wasn't named Jeff Berkowitz wasn't
named Jeff Bernhard Jeff Burkhart ya
know the the other part comedian
Jeff here Peterson Jeffrey people never
ceased to exist one right there that
fired on that one you tried to say none
of us are the real or real weed comics
in like right now I opened for Tommy
Chong so I go around you ready here
Geoffrey I didn't know that you get out
of your element a lot of people to claim
like you know it'll be like okay I'm
gonna be like a weed comic I'm gonna be
like the weed guy instead of just going
instead of just thing I'm gonna be one
of the weed guys right it would be the
main one title holder now I work for the
title holder I think choke dab to our
official port Wiley show that we didn't
have that time but like are you like
dropping names and shitty but no I'll
obviously like you think that I'm to be
like of course anything qualified of the
main guy to be the main guy but other
guys bro in Toronto that's a guy
everywhere is the guy yeah but every
city not every guy had the best we'd
ever brought no not every guy so tell
you be like okay this should be the swag
calm you're the rags they call you rags
Reggie Carmen oh my god exact Dixon
stands sad huh oh it's horrible did you
see yourself I'm sort of rub connoisseur
Emily what kind of story that means it
at all are you like you know like are
you like gonna fish you're not are you
like a the Lord bent a number water like
Oh like it has to be the best or he
slaps to a little handkerchief it's
funny I just want anything to give you
or had to be [ __ ] good
are you gonna go home sober no I'll
never go home
like if you will vote there's been times
there's been times where I've gotten
released from jail and I like someone
who's right there with a bag of stress
and I'm like give me that yes thank all
Jess - thank you oh you just need me to
survive it yeah that's pretty much it
man that's it in your veins Brown it
runs through these aren't even tattoos
they're just welts of weed marks out of
me but you won't you won't no I do die
open I try to smell the blood first and
then like sawdust no it's not happening
I see seeds of color of it dude if any
lime green dude if it doesn't look good
dude I'm like [ __ ] it says [ __ ] a
diva [ __ ] friend over here dog access
to other weed then yeah go through it no
access
oh no then you deserted island you and
open house um well I read and I just
seeded weed then I'm spending half my
life picking out seeds and the other
half smokin out we get a bird dog yeah
our volleyball other no smoking weed
again leads but there's no about
scraping [ __ ] pipe sports oh Lisa
told me I'll scraping the resident I
don't know bro we did a mass you did it
for me one time bros goddamn method here
it's weird when you do that because that
we gives you energy dude I've gotten
pulled over back in the dad's like 18 I
had a whole chunk of resin that I saved
him for a bad time and I got full dough
her cop tried to fit in for black tar
heroin he's all where the needles I'm
like for what
every tattoo what's going on you always
had bad luck with getting busted we
pulled over just for anything for being
brown on a Friday I get pulled over with
my tattoos and long hair but like cuz
I'm skinny they always think I'm a
method they're always like when was the
last time you eaten when was the last
time you slept
you bite is Apple yeah how about you did
you smoke anything or not what bud I
don't know man
some people had some shitty a Swede dog
and [ __ ] but uh you know one sister
here something like it was joint and
another Prix Road
again with Toby most Piero's you know
that you ain't you know you know you
know they probably gave it to you for
free will you about that stack ya know
or I'm pretty sure you can go all the
way to roll it up it's all tram you know
it's all [ __ ] once I know a shake I just
my pre roll like this I cut this get
some scissors I cut the tip I put it on
plate down it actually falls it's going
to trash pack loose shake you know man
this would be a good way to have a
booking Primo's you know ya dip in it
ya dip it in this would be okay
no lovely oh I'll use those I saved
those nasty free pills for when I'm like
completely drunk like leaving the comedy
store some just totally annihilate and I
don't care like I don't taste nothing
you know more anyway but cigarettes and
beer in my mouth so I don't care I'll
smoke that and I think it acts like a
placenta I'm like yeah I'm getting high
that's what I'm never gonna die I'm
smoking but how big was that [ __ ]
heroin dawg stupid ass cop
no no I was like in a little SIL
silicone container and he's like what is
this were the needles and I'm like what
are you tires oh that's resin and he had
the bus of the century and then he
didn't know what I was talking about I'm
like I scraped my weed fight and put it
in there he goes no it's not I'm like
smell it bro like if you ever smelt
heroin through the way yeah he threw it
away it's funny story about that that
cop really hated me cuz he took
everything out of my car yeah he found a
pipe and it was like one of those like
quad glass pipes so good to throw it
break it and it just bounces down the
street so he gets mad like sets it on
the edge of the curb like he's gonna
break it so he goes to stomp on it and
it just rolled off and rolled his ankle
and they had to call another squad car
swear to God so now he's like you pieces
like just going off on me man like hates
me and I'm like I didn't do anything
just that my fault have a great product
because usually cops are pretty hip all
right wasn't hip up coming shortly and
gentlemen I'm in Salt Lake stated this
week at wise guy is with with well Joe
Torre's John Johnny handsome and Tobey
Hicks Jordan landing location man for
the last had people hello utility move
on huh I don't know I think they are did
you talk yeah they're playing that going
through warrior bro almost being swell
the Cavs got someone did that happen yes
76 mm ones are done and then the
Cavaliers just moved up and then it's
over bro the Rockets right the Rockets
are no there's probably the only ones
that like [ __ ] stand a chance huh are
you gonna go for the rocket rocket
against the corner warriors you know
what I can't go for the Rockets out cuz
that's where the [ __ ] answers are
from so [ __ ] them to Doug about that
this guy in Houston one time [ __ ] every
team from there no shorty out to me you
know what brother somebody said you know
bro that's the [ __ ] punk ass logo is
the Astra holy [ __ ] that logo to way or
somebody said it was Broncos - yeah so
we must get off colors huh first year
out for this gray and black or get that
both paths are gone Raider colors a gel
outfit hey that's a Raider carry one so
I'm coming to ignacio Colorado at sky
your casino may 19 man Ignacio believe
it
hearted it to fly over there no matter
where your gold is gonna be a four-hour
layover no matter what two and a half
they want you to drive from Denver there
so the Debra into little airport Irvine
improv May 24th the 27th Miami May 31st
at Magic City casino I'm headlining the
ultimate Miami comedian competition and
clothing out with an hour's long
statement taking us to available day I'm
telling you
tickets are still available the movie
slow people come on how are your friends
I am before you the only time I'm gonna
be there or little bring back the Hard
Rock Cafe which they're not somber
Illinois somber Schomburg everybody in
Schaumburg May 17 2011 I mean really
outside 40 minutes I'm the first time
they booked me there up
Filipa we do not go away improv you're
excited yeah remember driving away boy
it got farther that way bro yeah suburbs
have a cool mall out there
yeah they do yeah getting up early huh
always you and I did it right
Lydia not pizza bro I had that big-ass
Chicago deep-dish you're not oh yeah she
O'Donnell's was some fool of Joe Torre
that's all coming up well yeah man we
have the June 11th show in Riverside at
the box of evil as jokes and also I'll
be at the obvious Long Beach Laugh
Factory
all shit'll be a Latino night LBC yeah
man stone arrivals coming now
yeah May 19th I'm headlining the Ice
House there you go a sadena just wealth
ontario improv and then june 28th we
launched the first check this out the
first ever we'd licensed comedy club in
America is going into Las Vegas Julie
the investor
I have Thursday night every Thursday for
a year I signed the contract so I'm
their graduation yeah it's gonna be
insane so we have the whole the whole
night so we can what if you're in Vegas
come by the whole crowd can smoke you
bring all the weed you want inside so
every tables gonna have a bong and
lighters yeah we have stuff for you we
sell paraffin no we do not sell cannabis
there you just bring it all we let you
smoke it bring your own we bring your
own weed BYOD what is that again this
launches July 5th and then it's every
Thursday in North Las Vegas it's a brand
new club that opened up what's a club
it's um it's oh my goodness gracious
yeah it's North Las Vegas with the club
21 and I've been wondering when these
cities who are becoming legal when
they're gonna start lounges and stuff
because these people can't smoke in the
hotel room can't smoke on the streets
yeah illegal so they're just like their
hands are tied they can't really go and
have a good time if they're just going
to enjoy Vegas so gonna play pay $250
for smoking in their room or not just
gets not get to smoke what they bought
and there are signs everywhere - now
those dispensaries have like a lounge in
them right no just basic like medical
looking dispensary it's called Isaac's
THC Club and the the Thursday night is
gonna be the laughing cloud cannabis and
comedy but yeah you can't you can't
smoke on the strip
you can't like walk in and go see like
at the Harrah's improv or the Tropicana
laughs factor you can't go there and
smoke weed but we're gonna have some
cool comics coming out that like our
headliners that headline Vegas and
they'll be in there and you can smoke
all the bugs you want you bring wax in
you bring anything cannabis you smoke a
plant but they're gonna allow all that
in there their retention it out like
yeah how much smoke is gonna be in there
oh we got great people gonna start fires
no no that started here on fire
now I'm pretty chic at Halle you just
had a job with a girlfriend you had a
tall child haha that is true that is
true nobody man everyone that's gonna
dab you saw the bar everybody to the
leather save time I don't know if I'm
giving the light or that guys lighting a
blunt in the back speaking of saving up
the audience I'm dr. ken bro he was at
the laugh out loud comedy club no
stand-up life comedy club in Arizona and
some lady was having a seizure in the
middle of the road in the front row and
then put I was getting heckled but we
were yelling her doctor can't help her
she's died and he [ __ ] resuscitated
her brought to her emits EMT got there
yeah dude the [ __ ] physician is
Amparo
he killed the Audion first of all I
wouldn't want to put anybody in the
Heimlich so I can get like some
liability going is there a nurse in here
called 9-1-1 I know but we're at the
airport I saw the old lady pretend to
fall off that chair bro the wheelchair
like she didn't get up on time and she
she fell forward in the back then
everybody helped her up no see they let
they get up that was holding me what
your he helped the rub but I could help
Rob to [ __ ] this lady I'm gonna put on
shoulder did that one time that old man
fell and he's all trying to get him up
and everything he's almost pulling his
back out more fool [ __ ] around [ __ ]
that old man get all [ __ ] up and try
to sue your ass dog I don't think it
could be sued any more for helping out
of here regular person professional
somebody in that position trying to help
them then that you can be sued I think
that's how it works not because for a
period of time that what you were able
to sue somebody hurt you while trying to
save you but I think it's business it
was it was a chips episode about that
they said it was the cop that moved him
out one of the chips and it was it is
another person then the person woke up
from the coma was it him you almost
messed up chips all mad over a person to
the event possibly at the airport today
for take it too long bro
oh that little one yeah we were we were
we were flying first class because every
time this time on our flight we have a
two hour less flight we have enough
miles to go first class we were first
class and and I knew like I could tell
that when somebody trying to sneak into
the line and they're lost but they don't
want to go to the other line
yeah she got in the first class line
right I don't think you were first class
holder should I'll teach you the ticket
for anything bro should have showed a
cute little cat that's in a Louis
Vuitton should have told that cat yeah
and and I'm sure they have paper for
that dog to fly that cat to fly so that
delay more time and then uh then her
whole her Louis Vuitton travel bag it's
a it's okay I'm not I carry on it's all
wrapped up blown as you go to Mexico you
want nobody to open it up yeah you can
open it up so they're all taped up so
I'm gonna take time now we know then
[ __ ] you [ __ ] is taking forever already
right don't you do the road talking to
us oh yeah other all friends oh are you
guys are all friends oh I like it here
it's curly huh yes dude were there going
man and then I'm I moved up next to her
cuz the lady fighting somebody else
opened up another were lying for us
she's still talking to us you get into
the gospel oh yeah that's where it's
over right there that's over she said
we're friends bro this was said not
anymore throw that [ __ ] anymore you
know I wanted to go off but I don't be
all like I don't mind dude sometimes
people on the plane so I get my [ __ ]
together man and then she stood blabbing
broad the place she has no ticket first
of all she's trying to buy the ticket
there she don't have no [ __ ] waiting
for the cat to fly bro and you gotta be
kidding me
okay so before I walk away I tap on the
shoulder excuse me you should really
really ask God to forgive you for
getting on the wrong line and slowing
everybody walked away Road and walked
away with my
well dude out of it I'm just be like God
hey before patient do you have brownie
travel at that oh I don't I don't have
no pail everyone assumes limestone right
right there I would have honestly I
would have caused this out of in the one
it's like this stupid [ __ ] like as loud
as I could like are you serious with
your fake-ass Louie Vuitton get the [ __ ]
out of the way you can't even afford a
ticket no one's gonna pay for you you
ugly [ __ ] how do it crazy bro and then
those it was like a Korean man there
with a family and he was like looking
they're like hey whoa yeah she was like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] it up for us right
now dude I'll shake it Maggie bass they
don't understand of travel one time I'm
leasing they were coming from somewhere
and the other crazy [ __ ] with a big-ass
guitar and ten bags bro so many things
no she said can you watch this and I
said you know really not supposed to do
that it's cool to be a good Samaritan
dude but no good deed goes on pony
what'd you do story robbed somebody just
[ __ ] drop the bags there and if you
watch this real quick and they leave
dude if I was just getting out of the
airport like coming back I would take
them carry-ons if they don't know your
ass if they don't know then he'll know
I'm not watching if I do something funny
they open up this she's not wearing your
clothes yeah I would totally do
something how do you watch it I would
want to help him out with Amy because
who knows if they're like a terrorist a
they would come back and I'd have all
their jewelry on potential crimes what's
happening [ __ ] leo this oh that um oh
my cupcakes bro you with my fat ass and
I'm just old rich old lady passed by and
she just leaves her dog where they were
I'm sitting or watch my dog okay [ __ ] it
serve it what watch my dog bro I shoulda
came back I'd have been like I watched
your dog get killed
I saw took them off with a little bro
yeah Paul Rodriguez a inside joke was Oh
chili dog right here with [ __ ] stoner
Rob in the house oh yeah well so fool
just moved early Iran deal that's how I
say that's not I know want to start
probably starting problems this John
Bolton dude you know that [ __ ] dude
it's like what are you doing dude and
that they're all trying that [ __ ] when
they all they gave Obama gave Iran our
money it was people are even understand
diplomacy dog over a [ __ ] 40-year
span this ain't nothing new just causing
[ __ ] friction dog it's like it's cool
alright we've been bombing people
whatever not will you better government
but you don't want to start [ __ ] on a
[ __ ] massive scale like that dude
it's not good if you follow it it's not
good it's not good Israel saying that
it's gonna create a Israel in Israel
Syrian war in Syria I think is really is
Iran war in Syria is what Israel is
afraid of not Netanyahu cuz we've been
pushing for this for us the other people
who are critics of what Netanyahu's
trying to do it's not good was so bougie
was that right like this is America no I
did not we had shows that night did you
see the video only video I seen was a
him of a music video where he shoot
somebody in the head that's that one
okay I just seen the intro to Vienna to
the yeah the whole the whole dancing all
that he's dancing mom he's mimicking I'm
the Jerry the Jim Crow oh okay
the wait dancing I think what is that
the Jim Crow the Jim Crow or the Bert
Williams Jim Crow what is that Jim Jim
Crow character or the Bojangles right is
type that that one yeah it's all that
well he's dancing he's doing that dance
Jim Crow oh [ __ ]
we reduce them Daniel Kalu yay I don't
know how to pronounce it live get out
Christopher get out anyway there's no
sound so it's pointless playing this and
what's everybody saying about that dance
and all that [ __ ] it just draws the
parallel between people today young
people today only caring about the music
that dancing the surface level stuff and
then they're ignoring all this other
stuff that's happening in in America Oh
death rides in on a horse and the cars
behind yeah yeah okay is that what I was
watching stuff like that all it was that
Jim caught away with you were dancing at
this so the doing the dancing you know
it during the song he's saying I'm and I
pretty and they doing that the same
faces as um at the black faces of the
old day playing the step-in Fetchit like
there would not say who their mammy
yeah I've seen my mummy was sofa where
people say hello from Brazil referring
tremendous how's Amanda and pastor note
is pastor there's also in America you're
a pastor now dodge it because you know
by Randy oh I'm an ordained I'm an
ordained minister right I should to not
the French of entertainment I mean like
like our pastor pastor the minister of
cheeseburgers
we had a non-religious wedding but we
were married by the officiant was a
pastor his side job is much it made
sense when he had his little pony okay I
do handle this weddings well you could
pay me I have like three forms of
cannabis weddings I perform that's why I
did it to do
I come over hi and give you DirecTV how
do we have a weed installer yeah man
you want me to baptize your kid yeah did
my team marry somebody - Wow I marry
Mega Man bro shout out to that fool that
bit that did your arm you pooping in
that car with a bit Mario 10 Mario
Cruise do not start drawing me you
already drew this Beauty and the Beast
thing I though man a little too free
with that pan with those old watercolors
man well so if you wanted to have a Pam
that we know they've been yeah that's
gross
no what are you something funny this is
waiting bro I tell this [ __ ] on stage
and this is a hundred percent true dawg
so I'm doing comedy with this porn star
and she's just sitting there she's she
only both feeling that Dave so we meet
at the ice house and she's gonna feature
so I'm chilling and we're sharing a
blunt halfway through the blunt so we're
sharing it she goes would you film today
and I was like I was doing a dispensary
release with Tommy Chong would you film
and she hands me the bump back and I'm
hitting it she goes I had a scene where
to eat a dude's ass for three hours and
then come over here [ __ ] I looked at
that blunt like
what the [ __ ] bro like that's something
you tell somebody before you share blunt
with him that you were eating [ __ ] I
know my shirt open earlier but we would
roll up a pre rotor yeah gave her one of
those hand-me-down silver
Silvia sage not she's a comedian and an
ax and a Porsche and a porn star Silvia
see show jokes yeah she does a lot of
anal style she's a minister too huh
no I was a missionary all day she knows
it's a that's crazy
she look at that person yeah whoa there
she is Silvia sage she's like I brush my
teeth she looks like a comedian not a
horse she's like there you go did you
brush your [ __ ] lips [ __ ] your teeth
you don't come tell me you brushed your
teeth after you ate ass for three hours
you gotta like bleach your face bro and
before you share a blunt with somebody
oh that's the business you're a bro it's
hard you know how to become a cannabis
Lord like they were saying you gotta
take [ __ ] blunts to the mouth I'm
asking for a taco shop update the update
is I think it came out on May 4th you
can buy it on DVD in a lot of places
bootleg it bro please I don't know some
select theaters but we don't really know
what's going on with that movie but it's
gone it's all bro really if you can make
sense of what's going on with Felipe's
character the facility's headphone users
they were to have laude
so one would you start doing comedy
Liam's no I done Liam so back in the day
like eight years ago we were still doing
Liam's that's funny that you say that
dude that place is a [ __ ]
but I started actually which was time
they've changed it like nine
that Colt one you walk in and it's like
a restaurant there's a restaurant to the
left a bar to the right there's a bar
and lounge old wallpaper now the stage
is straight to the back it's not to the
right no more it's it's like crazy
they don't do comedy there no more but I
started with Christopher Titus the first
time I ever did comedy because I was
doing radio I was on kcal9 t67 I think
it came down like Ross Ross so I think
we had you down when you're doing
Ontario yeah when you were doing the
Ontario improv and but we had Kris in
there and we're just doing banter and
he's like dude you should do comedy no
way that'd be cool I don't know where to
start he's all while you start tonight
dude you got five minutes I got a
sold-out show I'm gonna do my first-ever
comedy set tonight and that's where I
start how did it go Bridget a comedy
Pepe sure what happens now I just went
over there I opened I did five minutes
that was the scariest probably shittiest
five minutes ever done of my life is all
cliche stupid stoner jokes you know what
I mean and you're some cliche my want a
job oh [ __ ] like you ever smoked weed
with a Chinese man they can't get
Chinese guys they get blind I'll say
some dumb [ __ ] I would never say again
on stage bro
and it went good because there's a
Christopher Titus does everyone in
there's just like imagine a comedian man
besides him we show the worst comedian
ever seen that I've ever seen that will
you stay like when you first are used to
first turn it off you see some crazy
[ __ ] comedian started up
they're level yeah that's what I saw man
I must have said this already but man I
did a comedy show on time and I have to
follow a guy with a tuba well that will
close with guess what I'm done there's
no way so I know how to do it like
you're talking just any comic are like
known comic anyone but their names do
you see how bad it went oh let's see the
worst from I've seen a comic getting
knocked out what happened higher than a
giraffe [ __ ] so much weak though how
high the giraffe [ __ ] I've never made
me laugh I'm higher than astronaut dick
the best one man is with Joe Diaz say
he's high and then he mentions how high
he is the [ __ ] enjoyed that too but
smoked before he got shot sort of smoked
before you get the Comedy Store I think
the worst show ever besides the guy
getting knocked down shows that flow
yeah I know you're [ __ ] Pechanga this
is probably like I don't know six or
seven years ago still The Improv was
just comedy club at Pechanga it was just
common club at Pechanga but they call
patches in here no they call me to do a
spot and it was they called you yeah and
it was cuz I knew uh was it named Leroy
that was always down there and so I
Leroy Brown yep he was bad bad Leroy
Brown and I go down there and they're
like it's gonna be Chris Kattan and I
thought Chris Kattan did stand-up before
like all the movies and I was like oh
this is gonna be the range to minister
and it just that night
the party animals that's it went bad on
stage that hole what is this like you do
whatever our Chris Kattan bits like a
little bit more like our characters no
they're more like stories told like he
was telling stories and it just wasn't
going over like a lot of people like
some lot of the crowd was barely 21
going to Pechanga so they're like we
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about like a lot of these people telling
stories from his yeah it just was not
hitting and then the next night Will
Ferrell was there I wish I had a waiter
today I should have called him sick cuz
I'm thinking with the next one that wow
that's so yeah it was it went really bad
so awkward it was just so awkward to be
a comic that night like everybody like
there's looking at you like you were a
part of this like you cause this like
[Laughter]
what I've been like the moment when you
said man you know what I love doing
stand-up comedy really no it's more weed
but yeah when you wouldn't you combine
them together like you fell down or what
happened no well what happened was
because I'd always be doing the weed
stuff and so I started pitching along
with another comic named medicinal Mike
back in the day yeah yeah impression
Mike no black Mike he's Filipino right
he's dark and he produces shows no yeah
he puts on shows you should do slanted
within what is everyone that's Mike have
to put something in front of you got Big
Mike like Big Mike Mike Michael Rapaport
was always my white Mike we're going up
yeah that's so funny
Mikey Mike will call myself fat rod we
started him cons and be like these
things
and finally there's calm yeah him cons
we started hitting those up in like 2000
2008 2009 like right when we started
doing comedy
Saleucami and at that time I was like
just give us some weed we give a [ __ ]
about getting paid give some weed and
get a little bracelet and let's go to
him con the bracelet and now we do like
I I host the Boston freedom rally every
year in Boston
yeah in Boston it's hundred eighty
thousand people at the Boston Common bro
three days three days of just cannabis
smoke out that's September 14th 15th and
16th this year so if you're impossible
you hold the comedy side no I host the
whole thing dude like we chose I was a
lot of the big weed shows so I was the
whole thing I throw out like over over
$5,000 worth of product a day
Oishi I'll jaw shaking them down over
there week that dog goddamn Davin resin
over here in Las Vegas one time I
dropped a thousand joints from a drone
on the crowd awesome that was fun
make it rain who's fighting yeah both
your third marijuana show my first week
was probably hemp con it was him con
2003 and I just went to that one I
wasn't like performing there but I would
go to every hemp con from then on and
then I started doing the High Times
Cannabis Cup and I don't mess with them
no more but they would happen like
they're there let me tell you about high
crimes row they were knew there was a
stoner rod from nobody quickly they just
do stuff wrong dude like they take a lot
of people's mind it's like what just had
they they set up people in Las Vegas one
time in Las Vegas they didn't tell
everybody in my opinion because they
they told everyone they could sell and
then when people did the cops came in
and said hi times no you can't say how
people went to jail and then man they
were mentioned I'm cookies they gathered
those cookies and another guy they all
got message if I'm some guy going up
they're not gonna show up with your weed
ya know before the law passed yeah
burner and everybody
yeah certain people were getting emails
and certain companies weren't and that's
just weird dude trying to bash
competition oh yeah baby yeah baby first
one hero living arrested oh no we were
in Boston with Baby Bash last year he
had lined with Paul wall he was the
headliners of the freedom rally and then
there's always the Jamaican Cup in
November
hey you goldmine yeah that one's that's
the World Cup like the others the
Cannabis Cup in every state then that's
the World Cup Wow [ __ ] it the real
winners are anyone that could get their
weed to Jamaica without getting busted
yeah that's the winner
let's go Michael Silas wants to know
what state has the worst weed Oh
Pro from where I've traveled I have to
give it to Oklahoma Oklahoma has the
worst weed I've ever smoked like I've
smoked slag back in the day I've been to
Mexico and smoke smoke tire weed dude in
Oklahoma I still it's not tire weed but
they think it's good and it's nowhere
near good Danny give me the name or
something good but it not yeah they will
it's a lessons on the foot but you know
that she's ready they say no ATF I don't
know it's more like Oprah [ __ ] there's a
lot of shitty weed everywhere Doug
Florida had shitty ass weeds out of the
Queens
Reggie like stress I won't smoke around
you hold my oh ho ho type what if you
had what if you're there for five days
you can't get nothing else what you
smoke in a way bro no I won't wait maybe
four [ __ ] hours always wait them to I
[ __ ] lost a Jinbei bro
it always works there's always one but
also if I had that much I wouldn't ask
somebody Mac and you cooked it make them
put it all in oil and give me the oil
yeah and then up on you make brownies
before I leave I would still that's a
lot of work I would I need to get high
so I would still smoke it but I'd go get
like old school ways those flavor wraps
and all the flavored [ __ ] that people
like for they're nasty
yeah but bronies yeah you don't
understand in my life is heaven nervous
breakdown I go to jail and maker today
also I'm only there for 18 hours I come
out like [ __ ] everyone thinks I'm on
math and like novels like the one that
sends it running to that dude it's it's
not not as much no more now weeds legal
but see like I'll always fight for weed
so I always never cared so like like if
you're dude I'm like hey we're going to
we're gonna go to this festival and I
always have like a big tent because we
have our own companies and stuff so when
I get pulled over it's not like oh I got
pulled over last time with 28 pounds of
weed and four pounds of wax why so much
cuz I was going to an event like High
Times and I was going there because I'll
sell out of 28 pounds oh but you could
so are these events yeah I didn't know
that certain ones know anything for that
you couldn't but now they got their weed
license did what happened this was ahem
first of all with no license
the Hempfest in Las Vegas yeah oh she
lost his Instagram page for [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah bring it down I had my own
area so it's called stone Arab village
and what I do is I bring like all the
vendors that work with me it's right I'm
saying they work with me a lot and we
get a special price on a village cuz I'm
like you give me a price cut on boosts
but I'm bringing 50 booths you know I
mean so I gave the guy eleven thousand
dollars nine thousand cash the rest in
product for him reserved my spot other
people did the same thing
the day before he starts texting
actually I get a call saying that the
park said that he hasn't paid anything
and he has no permits and I'm like what
and right as I'm talking to my boy about
this he's texting me and going hey Rob
if you want a couple extra boost can you
bring me a thousand of my house right
now
and I'm like bro I just got a text that
says it's not even happening and he
didn't respond back and then he hits me
back and goes it's happening it's at and
then he hits me with the address of that
tiny little Club on on Fremont Street
that's right across from El Cortez
he hits me with Jack the Binion's no it
is this tiny little like they do like
rock and scarf it's right across from El
Cortez it's a little builders right
there's a boat we got over 200 venders
that's like what the National orange
Showground holds you know I mean we have
two to five hundred vendors there so
he's saying that it's gonna go there and
we're like dude there's no way my
village alone is 40 vendors and then I
see the the stuff they sent him that the
bar sent him and they said you can have
four Bender's here with only CBD no BT
no THC and I was like what so he doesn't
he wasn't aware that we're all getting
these same emails so that were like we
want our money back he's like oh no it's
just rescheduled and then starts coming
after all of us he's all Europe you're
you keep talking about this your
family's dead but like in this one man
is this Mike hooligan this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and this bull I'm like
didn't do something bro just come over
give us our goddamn money I haven't said
I was like the product I gave you I
don't expect you to pay for that that's
gone obviously but give me the nine
grand that I gave you so I give it back
to my people you know what I mean so
what I've been doing I've paid everybody
from my people out of my pocket so now
he owes me
9 grand straight up and he hasn't paid
anybody anybody get to action was there
actually a festival no what happened was
me and my boy Mike what we ended up
doing is I called this like wrestling
venue that's down there and I asked them
cuz they do a lot of like little sashes
there and I asked him if I could bring
my 40 vendors over to they're wrestling
set like festival this is like the night
before dude and they're like yeah can
can we wrestle and everything here I'm
like yeah cuz they do like weed
wrestling and I'm like it's crazy like
what's next like they got it goes like
those pounds like instead of the Bell
over the ring there's a pound and
whoever gets the pound first
and stuff like that but [ __ ] him with
the chair huh so within 18 hours we
turned it on and I had a whole festival
we had over like 800 people there so we
like we kind of saved a little bit for
some people but a lot of people got
screwed a lot of it like especially if
you went straight through him you got
screwed and now he moves cuz we knew
where he lived how much stretch it was
Pat dude that [ __ ] was empty damn damn
dee organize the festivals before yeah
and they've been good like we've hosted
them for the last six years and like
last year we brought our insane clown
posse Bone Thugs and harmony Kottonmouth
Kings the year before that Tommy Chong
afro man it's always been fun until last
year did Louie talk about losing money
too I was mad that they couldn't sell
like they were promising you gotta pay
you have to pay at least six weeks ahead
of time to have a spot and it was just
weird this year like it seemed like the
honestly dude it seemed like the dude
was on drugs like he was caught up in
life cuz I would make payments I'm like
like I pay half at the beginning and
then half three days before the fest
thats how a lot of places are like we
want to see the venue and he's like no
that's not how this is so just make
payments and he would like I'll be like
okay on the first every month I'll pay
you you know a thousand or whatever and
he would call I'd make a payment four
days with past but I did another
thousand I can't hold your spot you're
gonna lose all your cash in like what
even I'm gonna lose my cash you guys
have contracts to like written condoms
yeah they were weed lawyer and he their
names are the pop brothers at law very
successful lawyers except for this case
kobena munchies cuz this is Nevada we're
in California so this guy screwed
everybody dude and that's what happened
to that that was that sucked bro but we
got high with wrestlers and in a fem in
a cool time hello from Ottawa Canada
somebody want to know what the longer
you've been with us smoking weed well
here we go again
back to Jeff
I haven't [ __ ] go to jail probably
takes me like a day or two to get it so
the like a day
you're smoking there yeah oh yeah NGO
the good though
no I don't know what but as you say was
good yeah just whatever everything's
good when you don't have anything almost
it costs so in jail commentary I had for
Robins and then three cigarettes a joy
one joint painter how small was it
though like really feel like it's a
regularly it was like the length of the
regular skinny like 3 hits gone just
like joy beers gone with a Chicago Ally
McBeal bro it was an ally mcbeal JM yeah
like it is a toothpick will they like
[ __ ] suck up a cycle of so I gotta
let your blood spray oh I did I'm sure
there's a little bit bigger look a
painter late labor late leaving a half a
gram in there god no not even
there's no way 0.25 if that and how do
you get a little smoke it in there
oh do those matches yeah Zack did he get
you high yeah I got cuz you're not
smoking as much bro it's crazy like
weeds like what are the only drugs well
you don't have like how long those did
you smoke that [ __ ] you just turn it off
will you snorted oh no that's three is
three hits dude it was gone like one two
and then we tank there's somebody say
about this you know he'll know you whoo
tang in there you make sure there's no
evidence man you with the smoke will you
blow down the toilet flush it or what
now you usually just have you have a big
old rag and you'll just keep blowing
into that and then throw it into your
laundry you'll be fine especially no one
cares in there like they care more about
math and tattooing engine heroin yeah
what the heroin cause in there I don't
know I didn't buy any I didn't have
enough like looking at trying to figure
out what you could buy without
chuck-e-cheese tickets yeah if a guy
would have been y'all locked up and he
was a shove 10 cubed shoes instead ass
he'll come up in there oh yeah dude not
like choo-choo get that
commentary but you come up somewhat if
you come up with anything you take in
there in your ass except [ __ ] anything
anything else you'll come up there was
some fool Agito man what's this money
joint you ever smoked smallest join a
Pinner
some some fool back in the day but
there's a fool as what skinny has blunts
I mean not to [ __ ] on Toby but I mean it
puts a lot of paper in his blood stock
come on
puts a lot of ads extra paper we're just
a little bit of weed okay remember when
we're talking with homeboy that's right
now Eddie's got me roll blunt right here
I will I got nothing against it we can't
smoke in here but I'll roll it right
here right after but I can roll it yeah
I got my backpack Oh wonder wonder if
she's gonna come out yeah man I've got
your page and you'll be like dude we
love your page we're like like what
Google says seedless and Seattle bro and
they get sad out there our jingle oh
dude [ __ ] horrible and the sacrament
I let you the homies that we have in
every bag that's a common I let your
buyers yeah Naples yeah they have they
have dude it's mad paper out there but
it's all good they're doing better got a
little cold out on it it smells like
diesel that's working that's working
collected that's what Long Beach cheese
hang out they used to call her the
wookie and then everybody use the pipe
she look like everybody used to Piper
okie [ __ ] like seventh yeah you can
stop hanging around those kind of
friends yeah yeah not even everybody
would Piper but deny they would Piper
she working at tough though huh oh yeah
dude but then everyone had kids that
look like Chewbacca after and you just
knew she was down Barry down
stoner chick yeah party chick you when
you were growing up with her like stoner
chicks and you were mostly like with a
punk chicks
well like probably like three three like
three types of chicks I remember I had
my high school man like it was like um
good through the Cholas he can deny the
rich or last and then there was I'm the
girl that were more into like disco and
it was just a really really nice so the
dad had jobs you know the reunion and
then it was me I was hanging out with
the kids that had a skateboard with
different [ __ ] tires you know good
people that word I get to Punk and I've
been a STONER were somewhere else but
there was a beef between them did ball
hitting dudes and the longhairs yeah
there was always like fight supposedly
between the metalheads in us so we're
the same table yeah it's [ __ ] but
there was a goth people to the table
aside it was all wild fire homes it was
all white dog dad that's it [ __ ] it
those they controlled ah I wrote about
high school they controlled the the the
the quad like the main entrance to get
into the building
damn that was all theirs and then waffle
flats will be hanging around with us
through this door to tax fools mmm like
that like that and then um first she
cribs but be low low they be lonely bro
they be about himself East Coast first
week ribs they be by themselves but
everyone I want every once in a while
poor they'll catch a full sleeper by
themselves straight tune them up he's
hitting with a cane the other thing that
was there too is uh there was a you know
true leaders and we're always [ __ ]
trendy flavor of the month yeah perhaps
and what the [ __ ] what else yeah it was
hard to go from that group that I was
hanging around with she turned up be
with one of those girls that was
dressing really well today guitar like
my my my stylist broke there was my
black chucks for the rest of my life bro
and the group that I was with you know
but man over there was just into nice
and there was two other groups when I
was in high school there were the ravers
and the rebels do and that was kind of
annoying
basil story is like watching grease huh
to lease about it she was telling me
that I'm noble due to my daughter her
school I went to black school but nobody
was in to Madonna I was the only person
who dressed like Madonna
there were no Duran fans I would see
stuff on TV and and I'd be like well how
come it's not just black teenagers
weren't just weren't into it they were
into other things it was all about what
this eye went new editions my first
concert Bell Biv DeVoe something I
didn't like dread ran all those bands
and [ __ ] the 80s stuff I got just
because the older cousin he truly
television plays bleeds
I never heard Richard played something
yeah he wasn't out in Ohio
how about it was that Winkle Boingo big
out there when I was huge over here they
weren't big they were known you come
from the land I'm thinking the [ __ ]
about the butter the butter what huh
I got to change the words that African
song I think every time I see
yeah correct you are today with lyrics
under the lyric lyrics funny do you guys
remember that movie rad that BMX movie
in the brunette yeah yeah within a
weapon they make fun of it on American
Dad the comedian and Tony Hawk well
there that movie have that a song disco
fright so I aged over the words Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] but homie Justin looked
over his eyes it send me an angel you
[ __ ] idiot for 20 years
go on going to the chapel dude forever
until I was like 14 I thought I was
going to the jack-o'-lantern it's the
chapel dude I'm such a stoner had this
big ol thought in my head that there's
this jack-o'-lantern wedding chapel in
Vegas that's all Halloween themed oh
that weed that's oh you Roman give me a
big old zag
was the recording yeah okay sorry about
that
a lot of songs here we go know about
they didn't know the words bro
Oh a lot of them didn't remember Rob oh
man
their doors are bro howdy golly woman
that's better Thomas only Sunday
afternoon I should say a leave oh my
gonna have to do do your suburb Ritchie
your blues but there's suddenly
afternoon right yeah but I mean I didn't
know that's a cool little mix into it
though I mean if you can pull it off it
still phonetic with confidences yeah
like you knew it like I nailed it oh
yeah pussycat
I pledged it really here go seek out
there's no way it sounded like go see
Cal ever it's but you've played it for
me it does not sound like pussycat so
that goes yeah yeah go see cow tip
actually come in the end of your Swisher
it's a sign it's a circumcised Swisher
bro yeah that would talk to you should
piss [ __ ] uh Iron Maiden fans off
hardcore dog with that one on a peace of
mind just yeah how's it go oh every Iron
Maiden song ever made okay Big Bopper oh
hey you get sick and you get the flu
[Music]
just like fake history just to get
furious dog I'm here with a Haiti when I
did another word that literally come up
sort of chinos of weirdos add a stupid
ass but you know what I always thought
chicks were with her into that band that
music they didn't know every little
detail I don't even start like hearing
differences in the bass and the guitar
riffs and the drums so I started [ __ ]
puffin you know it's funny it's like
people like us could convince people
that they were wrong - back in the day
like that's not what it is it's this now
we feel stupid cos that I know okay
Google what is the lyrics and then
they're right on my call [ __ ] you know
it's not doors a lot of them probably
Isaac's dad used to think that when he
was a kid he thought tiny dancer was
hold me close her Tony dance
Wow be closer Tony Romani dance
chachi Tony dance and the Pope that's
what lyrics though I would always write
them down I would write them everything
that's what the cool thing is about
liner notes oh yeah the [ __ ] lyrics
have you noticed some songs oh they like
this the the lyrics are everything but
they're off one or two words sometimes
yeah and the liner notes about religion
I don't even see any liner notes anymore
do people put like aunt buy an album
without buying that well [ __ ] drives
me [ __ ] you know what Apple music is
switching I think by next year you can't
download anything can't buy anything
can't buy any music so you can only
stream they don't they think that
there's nobody who wants to own movie I
know that was one thing a bit of Amazon
they're gone yeah yeah and I think they
should continue throughout your life
opposed to just he even noticed those
people to just go they only listen to
the music in their time in high school
whatever [ __ ] all that dawg
yeah I don't know if you'll have the
option to like I mean I guess you hold
on to the stuff that you've bought
already but I think 2019 is when apples
switching tonight down with that Apple
didn't yeah but Google Play I think it's
only I don't know if he can download
maybe singles I don't know about a whole
album anymore have you opened up for a
lot of big comedians yeah like which one
partial meetings of like Chong obviously
pop comedian I've done I've opened up
for Doug Benson Christopher Titus Tommy
more Tommy Davidson the Wayans brothers
someone's day was in Seoul were party
sober Eddie Griffin probably more blazer
oh do double Kim [ __ ] Blaine wait
never [ __ ] works with earthquake nice
man well yeah Andrew Dice Clay at the
factory in a Tropicana will you open up
for him haha ladies are Blanco skinny
they're imitating light with wheels
no no but Joey Coco Joey Coco that's of
stoner have your cocoa working with on a
Rob who is stone Rob where's this blunt
we speak of bad dog fingers and would I
be real said about his joints I will
just smoking finger fatties that's what
that's a real [ __ ] joint
oh man shut out - I'm be real and Bobo
and the other do with them and I saw you
ran into him row that was tired really
runny - yeah
I was so excited but God said dog Oh dog
whoa walk away
nope no sorry bad dog yeah I'm sorry I
must have been named really about
nervous as a rhythm a name yeah rich
brother the podcast this will say oh
he's a brother two strikes
hey want to hear the third one would
phony sitting when we're getting ready
to get off the plane and you made like
an ashy elbows joke everything
you're killing me dawg but I don't want
to I really hate everyone that's a
Sagittarius he's a Sagittarius be real
talking about like we're talking all
types of [ __ ] I didn't know that those
fools were like there was a point that I
was worried they didn't have a good weed
yeah it was born with good weed well
back then it was there wasn't that much
of both you the bad times like the early
nineties like I started smoking weed in
sixth grade so like we broke all stress
like banana peels I got really lucky
because I'm on rules I did this little
like almost like it it's called hillside
but there's this one white boy that
lived next to us cypher the best house
in Hillside I have a little boat and
everything and one day I'm outside
dumping my seeds when my parents are
gone just throwing all the seeds that I
have gathered in my room just in the
lawn and he goes are you those aren't
gonna grow there and I'm thinking he's
like trying to be a narc or whatever get
on my case no no and I'm like it's none
of your [ __ ] business cuz I'm a
little bad think I'm a little bad ass
little stupid-ass I'm like no your
[ __ ] business he's like well let me
show you how real weed grows if you got
a second and I was like all right I
jumped the fence is full takes me his
house it's just hydroponics amazing like
[ __ ] so much weed hanging
in the backyard it's like a farm that
goes underground and just has all this
weed growing still living oh no I wish
too but he's gonna taught me how to grow
so that's when I started getting good
weed I was like oh my god there's weed
that doesn't have a bunch of seeds and I
don't have to take stems out don't look
like hey that's when I started getting
real good with that's probably like 98
yeah first time I seen Bob weed was 94
that purple plant dude first time I saw
it was 95 when I lived in New York see
the blue banach and stuff okay we I
think weed everywhere dude in my
carry-on everywhere that much no I'm
probably depends where I'm going a lot
of places I go to Ottawa
0:02 like Canada then nah I got
connections in Canada we'll get high
[ __ ] up there so like usually I I've got
it
to where when I land I'll pack it a lot
of weed I'll pass I could get weed like
a [ __ ]
I get weed pretty much wherever we go
and if not I you should create a new app
instead of like weed maps and stuff you
should create an app with people that
you can contact and those far away it's
called the black market set up looking
for a good raping tonight here's where
you need to go I know man if that's not
in pounds foot what the average pound
cause now now like it's all no right
yeah it's so fun like good [ __ ] like
this I used to beat you back an ounce
that's yeah I used to get like 400 gold
3,200 a pound now people are like oh
it's good can I get it for 18 a pound
like 1800 I don't want to give it for
under 24 but now you have do you think
with this being legal kind of saturated
the market with a lot of good but yeah
bad down real bad and you're seeing a
lot of what you think is good but that's
getting hit with a nasty-ass [ __ ]
amount of hardeners and G or no well
that's why I tell this fool like I can
taste it when it hasn't been drained out
all the way dude yeah it tastes the
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] that they put in
there yeah when it's not a proper flush
yeah you have to flush a minute
two and a half I think I know a lot of
good girls that flush once a week just
so that way that way you're always
pushing out old salts and it's not
gathering in your weed but dude weed so
cheap now it's insane that's what I love
shipping I'll ship out do-do-do-do-do-do
all over the damn place the last time we
see them also like it's it's just going
bro like we've taken two dispensaries
they flip it it's just not even worth it
trying to do anything else anymore the
dispensaries cuz they they'll upsell it
so they can pay more right now but
that's even gonna go away because they
they can't be after July 7th they can't
operate under medicinal anymore without
the proper licensing yeah we'll never
give you a bag like that and that [ __ ]
was whack and they made you say it was
good I won't say it's good right if they
know if they want me say it's gif
they're like if you don't say it's good
I'll take it back on hand it right back
to him cuz I'll bet that happened before
oh yeah a couple times just of my
straight-up level G going where they
Medici whack for me yeah dude she's not
worth eight thirty two hundred supposed
to get offended yeah they were right but
I tell and I try to tell him I'm like
like they'll come to me with something
and I'm like nah dawg I get that for
like a thousand of pound they're like
all [ __ ]
oh my dude I'm not trying to harass I'm
just like I'm like I get the hookups cuz
in the weed world we know everybody so
don't don't get mad at me they're like
[ __ ] you get that a thousand of
family yeah it's gross dude I've noted
that a lot of though the pre-roll that
are specially packaged a little real
neat they look all handsome the weed
never good
no it's always because they're always
putting distillate or wax on it and then
dipping it in Keith so a lot of these
cousin don't have no one
what was it name yeah drop it that quick
weed
totally yeah the bureau I had it came
with a Mickey with nice matches
everything it was six penis yeah it was
like a whole new light
good yeah like they fit more money more
money when a presentation bro so with
that man like not what it is right now
the packaging era is ended I think that
is people who don't understand that the
nuances of weed and so they think that
it just needs to be marketed a certain
way that corporate feel to it yeah like
they don't realize it has to actually be
a good product like just putting Katt
Williams face on it yeah smoke that [ __ ]
yeah these other states aren't going to
have the same quality weed as Northern
California because they're rushing the
production and that's the soil hasn't
had enough time to light all right now
you know is pushing the most we are the
most illegal grow-ups santa cruz because
it's like we it's like wine wine wine
wine you know like if you put out wine
if it's a new grape a new vine and all
that stuff it's not going to taste it
everything has to be what's the best way
to keep your weed fresh uh mason jars
are what straight sealed jars so there's
jars actually that you can get and it'll
suck the air out of the top of the jar
yeah like the canning thought that's the
best way to keep your weed and store it
in a dark don't put it in the freezer or
anything like that cuz you're just gonna
start freezing trichomes that'll shake
off keep it in a like a dark cupboard
that's not too hot but about 70 degrees
keep it back there your wheedle stay
fresh forever dude it should be bombed
forever
and like wax to your wax a lot of people
put wax in the freezer and then they
wonder why their wax is making noise
when they dab or whatever it's because
now you're starting to build moisture I
thought my bowl was cracking so that's
what it does yeah builds moisture so you
don't want to do that either dude you
want to keep everything if you actually
if you have a humidor that's the best
way give a celebrity smoke you all know
what the worst whatever yeah sad how
they don't know I had
was but I've had celebrity yeah Rolla
backwood and like I lived you wanna like
maybe they threw down half a gram and
then I was like all you want me to throw
some in tonight no you just roll the
next one and they rolled a backwood with
half a gram dude you wanna talk about
tobacco hi I was like oh well that guy's
risen aback would outfit no they got
that's half a gram on oh really
smoking it like it was like the first
time you ever took a hit of a cigarette
I'm gonna blow cigarette it was like
that
it was like that remember the first hit
of cigarette you ever took feel like
you're gonna faint oh god it feels like
someone just burned you on the inside
like oh that's what oh jeez
I couldn't believe that [ __ ] yeah do you
do it you get booted other comedy clubs
out of town I do a lot of state shoulder
just ponchos
I don't do I I promote your own shows
all the places I do other places I do a
lot of improv because I do I work with
the improv and levity a lot but I snore
- yeah a lot of pot shows though like I
travel around four states launching an
event our big weed festival I'm usually
there I get paid by somebody to go and
be there but I'm trying to travel out
right now instead of ales to do a lot
more comedy in other states like make it
down to Florida and go back to New York
like Dangerfield's and all that stuff
that's always fun but right now I'm on
the west coast and wherever John takes
me so I'm just working man yeah almost
do more sketches huh yeah yeah hit me up
Instagram I think a month ago yeah I'll
talk to Paris that's a chunk house is
always the great idea
it even says it but yeah let's do that
yeah yeah is interesting about a month
ago and said yeah you wanna do some
sketches yeah I was so mad weeding
coffee
[Laughter]
that way I was coffee boy and it will
have a joint and we'll just talk to it
in the gazebo that's like a total
opposite with ones getting you all
[ __ ] wired the other ones getting you
the coffee Cooney it has that it has
that pipe in it I do know I have one you
have one yeah we see once a word it's up
well maybe one no the photo I found
speaking of party man
well now when you were looking at me
bite your ear like a cocaine oh my god
we were in Sacramento we were at the
Thunder Valley Casino and we destroy
that plane amassed Lisa took care of
bookings it was like sold out show like
like a thousand people me Marcel
argüello Johnny with line for the beer
was food a whole night whole time either
watching our show like this there was
two lines to that bar on this side the
one on the right and we run it to this
couple bro oh my god bro I don't know
bro she was like fine know what to say
though we're in the room dog just come
back with the cocaine right here good
one bro each other that could have been
a good couple thirty years but how old
was that guy was older than her it was
like a bomb to know you know your boss
age right yeah lady was 45 she said he's
my boss
I like the way you said that like you
know this boss could still be their age
dad they're talking with a mouth closed
you can tell the old man doesn't do a
lot he like do little bump and she'll do
a couple gags he has to bro for he'll
die bro
so disappear with the [ __ ] house -
that doesn't even get hard-ons anymore
no way dogs not on coke there's no way
you were walking like he didn't care
though happy yeah I'm gonna join the
last 30 years I have left if I have 30
years another man will say he likes to
fool away I used to be a bar to code on
they're all bragging about that like we
graduated homes the carjack I used to
take bikes and [ __ ] but now I'm better
than that yeah [ __ ] now that the old
ass neighborhood pull apart Knights
Willow Creek were some fool chop people
it'll be it again may 19th the Ice House
June 12th or no yeah June 12th the
Ontario Improv June 28th Las Vegas at
Isaac's comedy club and then every
Thursday from June 5th on you could
catch us at the Isaac comedy club it's
cannabis and comedy in Las Vegas so
that's gonna be fun yeah we're gonna be
Eddie June 10th Long Beach Laugh Factory
with the Latino night with Benny manna
June 11th in Riverside at the Box its
people those jokes once a month show
Yemen was so full don't forget my Salt
Lake City I'm here all week man I'm here
Friday and Saturday Jordan Jordan
Lanny's May 10th row 12 Ignacio Colorado
sky you to casino Metro may 19th or run
improv May 24th to twenty-seven Miami
may 31st Magic City casino I'm
headlining the ultimate Miami comedian
competition Schaumburg Illinois June
15th through 7
team June 15 2010 at Schaumburg improv
outside Chicago check out other dates at
philippi WorldCom slashed or worse or
food don't don't forget to check out our
friends podcast
yo yo yo yo yo yo with Marty Moreno and
water and George Perez story was George
Perez citing any also the last vegas
show or the name career
tobey's yes I do cannabis club TV it's
the stoner channel so check it out on
cannabis club TV the stoner channel
you'll dress alone was so full shake a
March already has 10 podcast now one of
them what's up fool have a great week